flashing Casino lights and Marquees
aren't the only things catching people's
attention on the Las Vegas Strip so are
these mobile Billboards and County
Commissioners are considering more
regulations for them following some
concerns about safety and traffic Ryan
mathey joins us live with what is being
proposed
yeah Brian when Clark County first
started regulating these Billboards in
2020 they sent a hard cap 100 allowed to
operate here in Clark County ever since
they've been coming up and down the Las
Vegas Strip you just missed a giant
horde passed us by a few minutes ago but
the bright lights they're not
distracting from concerns that they
cause too much traffic and safety
problems I don't know where we go from
there Mike foland owns flow advertising
one of just 12 businesses awarded
licenses to operate mobile Billboards in
Clark County I have three but two of
them I can't put on the road because I
don't have details for them but his
license got him just one decal in 2020
meaning one billboard on the road and
ever since the application window closed
no new decals have been given they're
not alone competition into the market
even the people who are already in the
market they're not allowing them to
expand their feat to kind of to be in
the market the only new information in
the study from Kimberly horn is that we
need to do another study it's just one
dilemma brought to County Commissioners
on Tuesday they looked at a 2022 study
that evaluated 2.6 miles of strip
traffic from Tropicana to Elvis Presley
in it finding mobile Billboards travel
up to 15 miles per hour slower than
other cars are five times brighter than
the ambience Lighting on the strip and
contribute to an already poor area level
of service Clark County Commissioner
Marilyn Kirkpatrick these have no
business on this trip I didn't like them
before I don't like them now but it
seems like we're stuck with them so how
can we figure out it's the safest way to
go now the County's drafting new rules
including how to award the remaining 14
decals that have been surrendered in the
past two years but what that will look
like how bright the lights can be if
sound will be permitted and so forth
remains to be written
but Public Works did give some
recommendations they involve spacing out
these Billboards outlining a preset path
for them to drive and doing a whole new
study about how bright the lights on
these mobile Billboards can safely be
here on the Strip reporting live from
the Las Vegas Strip Brian Matthey a news
now
Brian thank you the county confirming it
first awarded 12 businesses collectively
that's about 100 decals now only five
businesses are active and just one of
those owns the majority of all the
decals awarded